def
ううううん
これじゃあ釣り社長ですはにいい
遊んでて海辺にいたら怖くないですかめちゃくちゃに madre 前のこと言ってる
と思うんですけど実際に遊んでいてその水ゲーとかでバニーがはてきたら普通の人だっ
たらも出身するくらい声と思うんですよそんな羽根が来る恐怖を体験できるような世界
実際役のおもちゃ
発見しましたまたツイッターでも見たんですけどもこれやべえと思っても即買いしまし
たこちら苦労答えるボート
見てわかるとおりバニーのラジコンなんですよではに入って効果なら全部出したを呼ぶ
んじゃなくて頭だけひょこって水面から顔を出してくれと泳ぐんでこれまずにそうなん
ですよこの同じ本顔だけ出てるんですよ悪いの早速挙げてみましょう
鼓動者考えると天才よ本当にレア様は兄が顔だけ出す周してうまいこと使ってんだと
思いました
おん
ああああああ
んああああああ
オーリャこいつ
a メーカーだって水面こうやって浮いてくるわけですよもう女とかめっちゃ
エルナンデスの無駄に何段この強さこれがボートですねなることでもこのボードさえ
つけるだけでこれでもこのプロペラでこうやって海の上をはせるという最悪
市場性虐のおもちゃだこれでこれ本当ローラーですね
電源度公開中で今ちょっとバックで充電中なんですけどもこんなは兄のおもちゃ
6匹ほど準備させていただきましたあの amazon なとかよく見るんですけども
目が肥えものに対してたくさんの間にが空ってこっくりミジュアルっすよ何体か
そのイメージですね一匹でも全然ない海でやるだと思うんですけどもやっぱりたくさん
来ることにより恐怖心を煽るという作成日記を時やっていきたいと思いますでも
とりあえずだかも
ポートだからさあ変な音出るとバレると思うんで1回どれくらいの音出るか試してみ
たいと思います
えっ
itv で早速モーターの音とか出さないか確認していきたいとおもいます
いじめ中華します
このはうわー
これでさあ地面が濁ってたりしたら怖いマナー
いきます
drawer
[音楽]
うん
全然許容範囲内音だと思うそこそこ早いのかなと
ん
過ごしているそうです
いや2な用途だとはいえサッカー以外だったら超せ
完璧コントローラー1個で2つ合成方はちょっと前でしたけど
こちら補正が一緒だった方もよく動くはずなんてね
周波数が違うみたいです it ちょっとコントローラーが一つ全部動かせないかも
しれないんですけどもまぁにマーカーをご覧くださいで微妙に顔に猫た餌があるんです
よ
ちょっとね色合いとか結構違ったりするんでなんか6台でやるです上から見てもほら
この子だけめっちゃ白いず読めよ個体差ありますというは編誰がターゲットになんと
なくなんですけどもはい
あなたに最近家の近くの海に何か万人が逃げ出したという嘘の情報を伝えておきました
か
いつもニュース見てくれないですが
ますまたゲストやってたんですけど
する側に
後に入れたんだよいい
両捕獲心経ぞ
なんか
まだこの前のサーバルキャットみたい
買ってるは逃げて
ねえぇがそいつ倒して俺の財布にしたろ
これで終わりか組2位と不自然ではない状況を作りいたしましたあなたはもう一ヶに
うまいことを誘導するかですねちょっといろいろ考えながら何とかして万人のラジコン
で襲われている曲を味あわせてみたいと思いますです号封筒
[音楽]
攻めたスマホ落としちゃって
とか本当に落としますか一見ならします
引っ越しされたんですよこの人
だよはい覚えてないですかたべコレコレだ
ちょっとヘアんにいたわー
ん
うん
[拍手]
[音楽]
何が悪いの
霧はみんなテロでございますよねあのございます
入ってあげてちょっと5人で6匹のワニは操作してなんとか県好きお宿に追いやりたい
と思います同じ手順で妻を亡くしたってそこらへんにいて
税方向から健介にはにが襲いかかってきたか
かて麺がさあ海でスマホ落としちゃったらしくてまずちょっとちっちゃくなっています
海であの市場の場所ですいませんお待ちしております
ごめん水没しちゃう
レーサー
縦面がさあ多分そこでとでしたいん
本当にちょっと探しねー
メディアケースでは優雅の泳ぎ
持って元気それは避難よ
やりすぎてあげるんじゃん
どこにあるわね歌うまんだがー
パパん
me
ページにしてる方と思う
[音楽]
ないかな
原型むしろしろ
rar ワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンポイント
飲んだ泳いでる覚えガッツちゃう
からだね c
wh
あっせずん
[音楽]
voodoo
あってちょ